[Applause]
[Music]
jaren deep in the corner gets Kaminsky
see if he drives him I'm gonna pull up
the distance I Drive right around it
spins which way did he get all the fall
back put him in a blender time out
Charlotte this is using his leg
whoa junior not fair
plus three wanna go ders pass but he say
right then splatted it go to the board
third third block shot for junior first
of all the ridiculous ankles and he hits
it and like you said it's not much room
over there you still able to stay in
bounds art goes out of bounds didn't
like what he saw there junior again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff Smith spinning away from troubles
Josh Smith what are you doing though did
a good job nice up fake then back around
and spinning around inside and he
catches my stuff around the corner
design nice little past and the big
federal agent is in lap 27 and 25 this
is rose trying to battle his way inside
lot of black jerseys the other one Smith
[Applause]
it's hard
come to life the pass-by sniffs but
chair by LeBron
I'm trying to do too much and Smith is
going to be the beneficiary with the
left-handed hammer did it to be but
because of his athleticism number 23 in
play left-handed sends it in pass out to
Smith launches a look he's quieting down
the crowd watch this catches it another
good contest by Richie Jackson nothing
he can do that's all over that shot and
a odd knocks that one down and he put
that little home run trot and then he's
talking to the cross and lie down
season-long James back in with Irving
Smith
Thompson and Shumpert JR Smith throws it
up and Thompson able of tip it home well
nice play off the dribble by junior
Smith again when he's put the ball on
the ground good things have happened
excellent attack and excellent father
Terry gets away from Irving pass inside
stolen by Irving throws it ahead to
Smith
[Applause]
Smith in transition recognizing the
locomotor running down the middle of the
floor is not how you drive it's how you
arrive mama there goes that man balls in
the air the only way you make this
happen
he went Williams leaves his head and
here comes Darren Williams giving it up
in transition to Derrick Williams for
the flush I'm lifting his shot and
making sure he gets up a arch
James with a lane good movement here
Smith the entry
but now LeBron started that play and he
finished it spacing everybody behind the
three-point line driving kick boom
driving kick pride the closeout and step
up and the guy who started it finished
it this is up pg-13 going right at him
spins away from trouble junior corner
three
[Applause]
I've been waiting for him to get his
stroke back it's been three games in a
row how about this for money with a
defender drips all over when it counts
jay-ar steps up big for the cattle lose
again if it ain't rough it ain't rights
the energy is definitely Hertha's again
both teams are trying to set a 1000
block from behind from kvar Smith nice
defensive play a great play by JR Smith
but once again he's behind it a three
yard to I think James drives on Iguodala
keeps his dribble along the baseline
back up top Smith from way outside
Smith from about 35 feet blocked will
and downs LeBron James showing that
passing ability finding jr. Smith who
steps in rhythm that's a tough shot
seven pertains here on the port goes to
Tristan Thompson JR Smith sign a lunch
habit and a foul he was close to the
three-point line they call it a three
they'll review it four-point plays JR
Smith with 22 points six of seven from
three-point range and keeping the Cavs
hopes alive of forcing that game six
still 259 remaining
[Applause]
finished by ish but John's you plan to
get MBA guards coming downhill for
school on who you are you can't cover
that guy by yourself come in George and
of course Larry Nance Jr their average
age is 27 I'm joined now by the general
manager of the Cleveland Cavaliers the
most powerful thing you said in the
acquisition of these new players was
that the old roster felt like a long
slow death march so I would ask you at
what point you knew you needed to make
fundamental sure the greenness
that's off Adams taps jr. smart played
with the long outlet Larry Nance
and jr. with a heads up long ball high
IQ basketball played never saved the
basketball going out of bounds
underneath your own basket since they
play by poor dance with a steal a front
[Applause]
motor defender any score it as he sent
ter dose it's West we go
yeah I'm saying nope I don't want to go
that way
backup is not to jump it down Geoffrey
no just came on
[Applause]
from the fat court and it went swish
shoot this cuz they're worried about
their playoff three percentage like you
say just the cannibal one leg three
knocks it down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]